- Personne n'est prêt à crier
au loup, mais tout le monde
se prépare au pire : le réseau
de la santé pourrait bientôt
manquer d'équipement pour
réaliser des épidurales,
une intervention couramment
utilisée, notamment
lors des accouchements.
MAÏLA TREMBLAY DUHAIME
enceinte de 25 semaines
- J'ai envie d'avoir
l'épidurale, fait que c'est sûr
que ça me stresse un peu
si, le jour de mon accouchement,
ils me disent : Non, Madame,
désolé, il manque de cathéters
ou quoi que ce soit là.
- Le cathéter épidural est
un petit tube de plastique
qu'on introduit entre les os
de la colonne de la patiente
pour lui injecter un produit
antidouleur durant
son accouchement.
Dr NIKOLA JOLY, prés., Assoc.
des anesthésiologithésiologithéc
- On sait que, pour les femmes
enceintes, les femmes
en travail, c'est la meilleure
méthode qu'on a pour soulager
entes. Et sans cathéter,
on se retrouve seulement
avec les alternatives,
qui sont pas aussi efficaces.
- Certains cathéters utilisés
au Québec sont en rupture
de stock, d'autres
sur le point de l'être.
Dr LUCIE MORIN, obstétricienne-
gynécologue, CHU Sainte-Justine
- Nous, ici, à Sainte-Justine,
quand on a fait notre
inventaire, on sait qu'on en
a suffisamment pour supporter
nos femmes enceintes qui
viennent accoucher ici au moins
pour tous le mois d'août
et probablement une partiedu mo.
- Québec et Ottawa font
actuellement des démarches
auprès des fournisseurs
d'hôpitaux européens
et américains qui offrent
des produits similaires.
- On s'attend à ce qu'ils
soient semblables à ceux
qu'on utilisent aujourd'hui
et qu'ils n'y aient
aucune différence pour
les femmes enceintes. Elles
ne verront pas la différence
entre cathéter et l'autre.
- En principe, si ces produits
sont rapidement approuvés,
la pénurie devrait se résorber
sans trop de problème.
- Il faut pas alarmer
les patientes à ce sujet-là.
On va être là pour elles, on va
continuer d'être là pour elles.
Il y a personne qui va se faire
refuser d'épidural
- N'empêche, un accouchement,
c'est déjà un événement
suffisamment stressant sans
avoir à se préoccuper de ce
problème, dit cette
jeune mère.
MIRIAN QUISPE
enceinte de 34 semaines- Maintet
ma deuxième grossesse,
je m'attend à l'avoir, c'est
dans mon plan, fait que, là,
mettons que j'arri
je l'ai pas, bien, je suis pas
prête psychologiquement.
- Trois centres hospitaliers
québécois, dont Sainte-Justine,
à commencé à évaluer
certains produits
de remplacement.
Ici Normand Grondin, Radio-C Rn